nesta segunda ronda pessoal mil que eu
acho que o vencedor com 260 mil por mês
lula ouviu alguma coisa muito aqui
[Música]
[Aplausos]
alvarez comandou essa desculpa que
passou passou
com ela também já pra vocês uma coisa
precisam ser nem dó mentira
micol eu tenho aqui um jogo para nós
fazer um caos com desconto é que na casa
o primeiro que nós vamos fazer um vídeo
que possamos comer doces como o 9o mil
dólares agora se viu mesmo tipo da
reserva no meu tempo todo
comprava tipo uma turma como mundo
caminhou sim é meu não chega chega e
sobra meu nome mas 40 coisa se eu fiquei
feliz com o meu louro fazer uma viagem
no japão fui eu ia conseguindo agora não
sei se lhe dirigia sob estejam 10 mil
dólares eo fmi espera que os mesmo gosto
para uma viagem acho que sou bonita e me
sinto seguro não é meu voto vai resolver
falando tanta gente feliz
embora eu como o dólar chega
segundo joão português não lhe o que eu
sou um miserável e se isso eu pegava nos
mil dólares de repartir por todos os
meus amigos e vou falar aquela ser é que
pode distribuir divulgar conteúdos é
claro em 2005 era uma coisa num protesto
maciço de mim também não jogando legal
eo que tu fazes com um dólar e que
depois descobriu boas então sua oficial
aceitaram jô
pronto já preparar a tropa de choque
quero falar que seja muito bem vindo a
mais um vídeo e este é um dos pontos
conta que na nova casa para lá regras
existem regras só então como é que vai
funcionar que o jogo estilos rondas a
primeira ronda só para treinar ok só
prevemos aqui algum espaço aqui na casa
tem que ter em conta que só segunda
ronda cavaleiros então guardei o melhor
sítio para o fim e você não apanhar as
duas rondas o primeiro que acompanhar
vai me ajudar e tentar encontrar os
outros o que é essa regra e outra coisa
importante vocês vão ligar todos os
nossos telemóveis vão filmar onde estão
escondidas porque você tem um vídeo eu
só vou saber pois quando fui perguntar
então vamos fazer assim vai na primeira
ronda última sido apanhado dos 100
dólares é fácil falar uma coisa de freio
os três só vai ser bem divertido já
deixou o vosso pai que inscrevam se
envia espírito diz bachman pelo whatsapp
para lá chegar aos campos com devo
começar a cantar 112
acho que o acompanha chico 458 nó 21
2223 não demonstrar isso é uma forma de
acesso àquela que vendeu 28 29 30 aqui
vou eu pessoalmente começar aqui por
baixo eu acho que ninguém tinha o
movimento de se esconder aqui nessa hora
eu duvido muito mas vamos ver
toque por trás tem alguém aqui que
vencerá
eu tenho certeza com deus deve estar
escondido dentro de um armário muito
porque tenho quase certeza eu tenho que
fazer tudo pra galera mil dólares ou a
alguém eu acho que a droga
querido estranho né sorriu adilson casas
o que eu estava muito escuro é que você
ver os outros estão sim o que não só
tenha certeza que ela está aqui nem lá a
a luva feita de graça é quem está aqui
quem vai ser o primeiro a ser lançado é
procurado por ninguém
quem está aqui por trás e ninguém aqui a
não tava no total 11 por cima muito
estudo
ok aqui está tudo vazio para o passado
ou outro mas ninguém vai entrar hoje
escolhida kinect é um fato azul que não
faz isso ou a porta do meu quarto estava
se inverta eu tranquei a porta do quarto
mas tem alguém recorda num saque não é
legal
a copa vai aquecer a copa não gostei do
senhor
a minha tia trincada portas yoko qual
ela só encontramos o senhor já não vai
ganhar os 100 dólares já só faltou pio
dante silva agora vai me ajudar para que
os encontros se o ppe o dante eo windows
símbolos 4 bi esta porta aqui antes de o
dia estava vendo está pensando agora
ficar alguém daqui da janela aberta
lembro que eu duvidar expirar em dúvida
se afastou e não sou eu é muito incrível
estivesse escondido dentro da câmara
o maior maior do sul vai ganhar 100
dólares não vai ganhar sempre esgotado
nas juros junto é um gênio da motown foi
dentro daquela olha só por isso vou dar
100 dólares toma muito tempo lá dentro
você não tem salto e passou a não tá
aqui pra ganhar 100 dólares por ser o
vencedor vai ganhar 100 novas escolas
que nos conduziu o lei assim eu estava
muito próprio muito bom
então se o canadá um meio tão furioso
isso foi já disse que talvez lá em baixo
da garagem
você não é um gênio que os gênios no
geral após imaginário em cima da janela
tomávamos a segunda porque eu tenho dois
cantores gaza nesta segunda ronda
pessoal mil dólares com o vencedor 123
então deus tem já que já pensou certo
que o começo dos 60 internet ou negras
onde é que eu tô ou não diga não digo
mas não faça boa figura
nós três 14 anos acaba de 19 20 21 23 24
e se sobrar
já estou querendo carro 28 pinaud pinta
como sujo - candinho dó onde a cantora
estava aberta uma janela aberta
a all tem seu por aqui por aqui
como assim o diz fora da casa envolvia
pessoal ou por isso eu avisei que não
vão lá fora da casa
vou começar a fazer agora um vídeo como
ganhar mil dólares fácil só eu avisei
toque pessoal eu acho que eu já sei o
que eles fizeram eu acho que eles
abriram uma janela para enganar primeira
noite fora investir em alguém e eu agora
entretanto subiram aproxima tem quase
certeza que fizeram isso então eu já vou
lá assim mas que estão a ver se um gênio
é gênio da música na primeira ronda eu
sei o que vocês têm que deixar meu eu
estou muito próximo e abriram tudo
fizeram questão de abrir as portas todas
só para enganar como é que é possível
mas pelo apelado espera lá esperava que
eu não confirmei que por mais nove que
tem mais irmãos que nem sempre é assim
[Música]
dentro eu tenho que manter cirurgia
durou a soja vai quase militar que só
vamos lá tentar encontrar o piloto agora
a calma calma calma eu não vi os a usar
todo o seu poder é que eu posso fazer
isso aí sim eu sei eu sei que sim é
possível confirmar eu ir embora
acho que foi a calma só usando as
câmeras da prefeitura que não é
coincidência coincidência eu não vi o
filme
tá aqui
ap o derby está aqui agora
aqui o cidadão não foram no entanto
dentro do carro mas o carta fora da casa
mas o carro faz parte da casa dentro do
carro possante comércio renesmee bom e
eu fui mais original possível não tipo
disseram que vão ver a casa toda os
carros também valem os carros onde
importa casa com a bm faz parte da casa
por isso escondem dentro também anotou
na rua tem de direito nessa lânia nós
temos que ir porque eu vou poder mil
dólares como absurdo fez batota não fui
mandando nos dez no total
assim foi o último a ser encontrado e
agora não quer dois mil dólares em
gastos costumam se encontrar pela
história do caso não fora da casa estava
dentro de casa bem também faz ponta casa
meu como aceitar valioso mercado
esperando espera se o pacote gestor não
eu não goste ou não eu acho que a nossa
eu acho que não é justo dentro das
regras que tu disseste exata mas caiu
também não acho justo mas diz que vai
ficar nas mãos do pessoal lá em casa
vocês vão comentar a subir merece já o
torna você tem que comentar que se
merece vocês já sabem que o mulheres mil
dólares como em tempe mil dólares
vocês acharem que não merece comenta em
perm o dólar já caiu da pimel do lance
sempre só ajuda o jipe mil dólares acho
que foi o dinheiro quando o meu primeiro
filho eu acho que a gente usa meu os
nossos fãs é que é excelente e agora o
menino que também merecem dourada
o mesmo do brasil espero que o esperado
para ser justo para quem cumpriu todos
os requisitos só para sustentar 59 50
dólares
muita gente não me sinto agora talvez
talvez ei só vez foi o vídeo hoje
continuou na casa nova já sabem comentem
se querem qo piercing mais mil dólares
ou não e se quiserem a parte dos carros
todos agora vinha conversando
não vou perder dinheiro não quer perder
nenhum software é parte 2 comentei hora
choveu o que eu quero de volta